[Musique]
il existe un lieu comme on en voit nulle
part ailleurs sur terre pour y survivre
t'es qui toi juste il faut être fou ce
que j'aimerais c'est que vous me fassiez
un doux et fort heureusement c'était mon
cas car et je te donnes tout ce que tu
veux mais quand c'est aussi gentiment
proposé
vous avez vécu à tropa from certaine
attirance pour ce qui touche à la
souffrance et aux maladies je vous
demande pardon
qu'est ce que tu fous dans cette boîte
il faut bien manger
je suis monsieur franck je veux que j'ai
lu minuk les cas pour moi on va avoir du
talent sappi total c'est une véritable
invitation à l'anarchie g gravaud à la
bouche
une infime j'aimerais que vous avez
humilié au prince est associé à une mort
imminente
c'est ce trail délit presque burlesque
tu ne viens pas vrai boulet au plus tard
[Musique]
un de ces quatre fausses demandes enfin
si je te flatte pas tu es là
c'est moi qui tire les ficelles tu n'es
qu'une dresse hypocrite une
manipulatrice insensible une seule
petite chienne trop souvent pour que je
me le rappelle